we already knew watchdogs two would be
getting DLC but now we know what that
dlc actually entails I'm Tony and this
game spot news update has extras the
first DLC pack drops in December and it
brings a new vehicle outfit and co-op
difficulty level called mayhem which
adds an advanced enemy type the next two
packs are planned for spring 2017
they'll add new missions and a co-op
mode called showdown although details on
these are little scarce all three of
those are packed into the game's $40
season pass which also includes the
psychedelic pack and root access bundle
which come with outfits and vehicles and
the special zodiac killer mission note
that all of this content is coming to
the ps4 30 days before it hits other
platforms watchdogs to launches on
November 15 for ps4 and xbox one it's
coming to the PC on the twenty-ninth the
season pass will get you all of this DLC
but there's currently no word on what
those packs will cost on their own to
keep up with all the latest from
watchdogs and Ubisoft you're already in
the right place
Oh